[Music]
so you're the heads of china it's a
well-known fact that you have the
ambitions to take over the world and
you're growing at a very fast rate one
of the ways you're funding your goal of
world domination is with your belt and
road initiative i plan to make it easier
for anyone to trade with china by
creating a modern day silk road of
railroads highways electricity grids
seaports and much more by partnering
with nearly 70 countries because you're
growing so much your energy demands for
electricity oil etc are higher than ever
and only gonna keep growing but then you
run into a problem the original silk
road that connected china with the rest
of the world runs through an area of
china called xinjiang
china's gateway into the western world
by land
xinjiang is also home to a ton of
natural resources that you desperately
need if you ever hope of achieving your
goals it has nearly 40 of your coal
reserves 25 of your gas reserves so in a
way xinjiang is your most important
piece of land
now at first glance this is great
because xinjiang is already a part of
china but beneath the surface however
things aren't all that well and dandy
see unlike the majority of china
xinjiang is home to an ethnic muslim
minority called the uyghurs they look
different from the han chinese the
ethnic majority of china they speak a
different language than the rest of
china but most importantly they have a
completely different culture than the
rest of china a culture that's much more
similar to the neighboring turkish
countries than to the chinese now you're
not dumb you know that a society's
culture is the root of everything the
chinese culture that you've worked so
hard to maintain is what allows you to
rule over your plebs in the first place
but then comes along these disloyal
outsiders with a completely different
culture that threatens your entire
scheme
if this minority doesn't feel like
they're a part of chinese culture they
could become separatists and want to
form their own independent nation like
they have in the past
effectively throwing a giant monkey
wrench into your plants by taking
control of your most important piece of
territory and the central government has
long regarded this ethnic minority
community predominantly uyghurs
uh as disloyal
so it's pretty safe to say that if you
don't do something about this little
issue we have here everything falls
apart you need to crush the weaker alien
culture you need to brainwash them into
being dependent on the ruling class
[Music]
and what better way to do so than with
the time-tested method of concentration
camps
it looks like a nazi playbook to me
zen's estimates up to 1.8 million
uyghurs and other muslim minorities have
been sent to the camps since 2017.
this is a story they don't want to get
out
[Music]
we would call that brainwashing
moment
it's probably the largest internment of
an ethnic or religious minority since
the holocaust
now you've been aware of this problem
for a while but you can't just all of a
sudden build a concentration camp and
start throwing people into it no no no
no if you want change you gotta ease
people into that change in fact you the
government have already been
incentivizing your native han chinese to
migrate into xinjiang since the 50s to
ever so slowly dilute their culture and
although it did work the han chinese now
make up almost exactly as many weakers
in xinjiang the weaker people aren't as
docile as you once thought and in 2009
those disloyal outsiders finally thought
that they had enough and erupted into
violent riots against the han chinese
now if you've watched this channel for
any amount of time you know that when
there's a crisis there's a sweet
opportunity so here's what you do by now
you know that concentration camps are
really the only option left but things
are pretty heated right now and although
you can just detain everyone it would be
a logistics nightmare and would cause a
lot more controversy than needed so you
gotta calm things down and figure out a
way to id the people committing thought
crimes by turning xinjiang into a
tyrant's dream
you cry like these people are extremists
that they're infected with religious
extremism and that you need to flood the
city with police and 24-hour
surveillance to keep the peace now
whether or not there's any truth to this
it doesn't matter it's all part of the
plan have police stations guards and
armored vehicles on every corner
condition and exhaust everyone by making
them go through security checkpoints for
each and every aspect of their daily
lives to be in xinjiang means being
checked every day multiple times a day
when you go to a market when you drive a
car
when you take a train
check their phones at these checkpoints
to make sure they haven't committed any
thought crimes by having the wrong app
installed rakima senbei who now lives in
kazakhstan spent more than a year in the
chinese camp system just for having
whatsapp on her phone and since you have
such a good excuse for all this
protecting the public you can use this
as a testing ground for the most
futuristic surveillance equipment before
rolling it out to the rest of china
you can easily make the lives of the
centers and minorities very difficult
residents have different levels of
freedom based on factors like ethnicity
and religious practices you can prevent
retaliation by tying the purchase of
kitchen knives to people's ids by laser
etching a qr code on the potential
weapon but most importantly you can use
this police stateless police presence to
categorize people as safe regular or
unsafe there are a few ways you can do
this you can force everyone to fill out
surveys about themselves and their
beliefs when that doesn't work you can
just rely on analyzing people's
movements on surveillance cameras with
ai to see who's walking too fast who's
parked in the wrong spot who jaywalked
and of course you can rely on just good
old-fashioned police intuition once you
do categorize people well we obviously
can't have people deemed unsafe roaming
the streets now can we so what do you do
you round them up and move on to the
step we've all been waiting for our good
old concentration camps
[Music]
now that we have our advanced police
state up and we singled out all the
trouble makers it's time to start
building the concentration camps but
here's the problem the idealist in the
west would never approve of such
inhumane tactics because of the history
associated with them now you know you're
not gonna go laugh or at least not yet
you're only looking to destroy their
culture to forcibly assimilate them to
your more obedient chinese culture so
you gotta hide these camps from the
public eye as much as possible but if
word does get out we gotta make sure our
bases are covered so instead of just
calling them outright concentration
camps we gotta put some makeup on it
re-education centers
re-education centers transformation
centers so you start building but how do
you build these camps you may ask just
like a prison sorana and barbed wire add
watchtowers along the perimeter flooded
with even more cameras than the city and
make it look very dark and dreary to
crush their spirits unlike a prison
since our goal is to re-educate them we
gotta have some brainwashing moves i
mean classrooms where we can teach them
the proper way to be an obedient citizen
one more thing to keep in mind is that
there's a good amount of these outsiders
in xinjiang around 9 million people
that's a lot of people to potentially
keep in these camps so we gotta make
sure we build these as big as possible
all over the region
since most of these people aren't
necessarily violent offenders yet you
can get away with squeezing 10 of them
to a room and making them share one
toilet on the ground to be as efficient
with your real estate as possible and
don't worry yes this is going to cost a
lot of money to build and maintain but
just remember how important xinjiang is
to us the roi of tightening our grip on
this region will be tenfold once these
camps are open for business it's time to
start busting people in keep your
requirements for detaining people for
education and training very loose oh
you're worried you won't be able to
arrest people before they commit a crime
relax and just take a page out of the
popular tom cruise movie minority report
and use the justification of pre-crime
i'm placing you under arrest for the
future murder of sarah marks and donald
dubin that was take place today april
22nd
so you have the camps up you got the
pre-criminals in but how do you actually
re-educate them
[Music]
we basically want to turn these
prisoners into docile obedient and loyal
citizens which entails making sure we
break their spirit to prevent any
retaliation or extremism and
assimilating them into our culture you
gotta break them
you gotta break them like dogs
break them yeah break them like dogs so
just create a how-to guide for the
people running these camps around this
goal of course you want to do all the
typical stuff you find in a prison
controlling their every movement
preventing escape really maintaining
that atmosphere of hopelessness to break
their spirit but assimilating them into
our culture is going to take some more
work you can't feel a part of a culture
if you don't speak the native tongue so
make them learn mandarin
replace their faith and culture with
learning about chinese culture then they
switch from uiga their mother tongue to
chinese lyrics
written by president xi jinping
train them to fear and be loyal to the
ruling class and the replacing of faith
and cultural identity with a different
loyalty i love the communist party of
china this man has written
if they're ever released if they just
have a bunch of free time on their hands
to ruminate and become vengeful against
the government all your work will be for
nothing so you gotta make sure they're
able to stay busy by focusing on their
labor if they ever get out so train them
on how to do very entry level jobs
and lastly but certainly not least while
you have all these people captured you
might as well use them as cheap labor
if you have any prisoners that aren't
complying you know what to do
get the system up and running scale up
to 1.8 million prisoners since 2017 and
you sir have just created a successful
network of concentration camps
but with 1.8 million people the friends
and family of that 1.8 million people
everyone involved in the project and the
power of the internet and satellite
imagery word will eventually get out
about your camps and how inhumane they
are and how we shouldn't do business
with china because of their human rights
violations how are you gonna handle that
[Music]
now obviously we don't care about what
the world thinks about us but we can't
afford to lose any business so once word
does get out you gotta suck up your
pride and control the narrative at first
see if you can just delete and deny away
any evidence from the internet as soon
as we began to document the re-education
centers there was chinese government
officials deleting what we were finding
if that doesn't work and the story
starts picking up traction around the
world it's time to take a page out of
your neighbor's playbook north korea and
put on a show select one of the camps
you build to act as a showpiece for the
world get rid of those orwellian watch
towers slap on a new coat of paint and
add in some recreational stuff
only keep your best most re-educated
prisoners there and move the rest to
other camps dress up your prisoners and
knock off adidas tracksuits and let a
select few journalists in while closely
watching over them to make sure they
don't ask too many questions control and
schedule everything they see and train
your staff to know exactly what to say
it doesn't a place where people have to
come obey the rules stay until you allow
them to leave sound more like a prison
even if it's a prison in which you can
do some all right
[Music]
whatever you do just make sure people
look happy and that they're willing to
be there even though most people won't
believe the charade that's not the point
the point is to get as many conflicting
viewpoints out there to blur the
perception to instill just a tiny bit of
doubt in the back of people's minds
about what's really going on
with 1.8 million people you're
eventually going to have some
whistleblowers but there's a very simple
solution to this even if they're able to
get out of the country to tell their
story they probably have family that are
still in china that you have on record
so just kidnap their family to scare the
whistleblowers into silence six days
after i talked my sister and my aunt
both got abducted the same day as a
retaliation for my activism you don't
think it was a coincidence i don't think
so
and boom in one somewhat swift move that
did take a couple years but it's still
pretty impressive in the grand scheme of
things you've gained a tighter grip on
the territory that's vital to your quest
of world domination and you've got those
pesky outsiders under control while
you're re-educating them into more
obedient members of society have you
been convicted of a crime
and don't worry if for some reason a few
years passes by and they just don't seem
to be getting it
well i'll just leave it at that
welcome to the watch the end club it's
kind of stupid that i have to say this
but i do not support these things but if
you want to change something it helps if
you understand what you're changing and
where the people you're disagreeing with
are coming from because if you don't
understand where they're coming from
what do you end up with the war on drugs
fail the war on terror fail the war and
alcohol also knows prohibition fail so
yeah that was my rationale if you're new
to this channel and you're still
watching right now you're obviously
interested in this so just click that
subscribe button below because you'll
get free videos like this every single
week on the most provocative stuff in
the world of business the comments
section is getting pretty absurd and
it's very entertaining to read so you
know keep it up happen to be looking for
a remote job while you're in quarantine
and you also want to support this
channel financially well it just so
happens that i offer the exact resume i
used to land my 40 per hour remote web
dev job at 19 and it has some pretty
clever marketing tactics to help you
stand out from the pool of job
candidates which you can check out for a
very small price with the link below you
guys asked for patreon we announced the
trend crime family last week you guys
asked for a discord server you guys get
a discord server that you can join with
the link below where you can hang out
and talk about your struggles with
running internment camps you can follow
me on instagram jaketrend.io that is
gonna wrap it up for this very
ridiculous outro thank you so much for
watching you've been awesome i've been
jake i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you